OK, it is time for a weekly coronavirus update,
I think weekly is sort of the right timing
to do.
These were now not really following day to
day data, but more looking at things week
over week and looking at trends and changes
to cases and deaths and vaccinations.
So let's jump right in.
Things are still looking continually better.
They're looking better than last week on average.
But there's now sort of a word of caution
about some of the last few days of data.
And again, because we're looking week over
week, I don't think we should read too much
into it now.
But I'll explain momentarily.
From the standpoint of coronavirus cases,
cases are now down 72 percent from their average
peak, which took place on January 11th.
On January 11th are seven day average was
two hundred and fifty five thousand new cases
per day.
When we think back to June of twenty twenty,
when Dr. Fauci said if we're not careful,
we might get to 100000 cases a day.
And many, Denyer said that'll never happen.
And we got to 100000 in 150 and 200 and we
were averaging two hundred and fifty five
thousand new cases a day.
The week of January 11th.
We are now down from that peak by 72 percent,
72 percent decline in new daily cases to about
70000 per day.
But and here's that word of caution.
The decline has leveled off in the last few
days and there was even a slight, average
day to day uptick yesterday.
Now, a lot of people have been asking and
e-mailing me and tweeting to me, is this an
actual reversal or cases now going to go up?
I don't think so.
I think it's possible that if indeed the vaccines
are shown to be ineffective against the primary
variants, that in a couple of months cases
could actually start going up in earnest.
I don't think that that is going to be the
case, but that's not what we're talking about.
Now, what is going on right now is that because
of the terrible weather in much of the country
last week, testing and reporting of cases
was slowed down.
So most likely there were declines that were
reported late last week, which were bigger
than the real declines because weather stopped
a bunch of testing and reporting.
And now as the reporting gets caught up and
people who should have been tested Friday,
Saturday, Sunday, but weren't because of bad
weather are getting tested and are coming
back positive.
And so the numbers are kind of leveling off
and appearing a bit higher.
I don't think this is a real reversal.
I think this is an artifact of the reporting
changes because of the weather.
Now, in terms of deaths, the numbers have
also improved dramatically.
Unfortunately, the numbers were so bad when
it comes to deaths that even these improved
numbers are still completely tragic.
But deaths are down 38 percent from their
mid January highs.
Deaths were peaked at 3400 per day.
They're down to about 20, 100 per day now.
Twenty one hundred per day is outrageous.
It's an outrageous tragedy every single day,
but it is a decline of 38 percent and similar
to cases, a small uptick in the last couple
of days, also believed to be because of lower
reporting due to the bad weather late last
week, which is now recovering.
And the data will sort of be shuffled around.
And I think we'll be back to kind of normal
day to day tracking within another 48 to 72
hours.
We'll know in the next four to six days whether
there really is a reversal here, cases and
deaths leveling or even even going up a bit,
or whether this is just a reporting artifact
and cases and deaths will continue down.
Now, much like case and death reporting was
slowed down because of the bad weather.
So we're vaccinations slowed down.
We had actually gotten up to averaging about
one point seven million shots per day.
But because of the bad weather and important
to understand, the bad weather affected vaccinations
in the states with the bad weather like Texas,
for example.
But the bad weather also affected shipments
of vaccines to more of the country.
And last week, we saw vaccinations per day,
a drop from one point seven million a day
to one point four million a day.
Now, that's still much higher from where we
were January 20th, for example.
It's not high enough.
And Dr. Fauci says he's confident that the
doses are going to be made up for in the next
week or so.
Let's hope that happens.
And obviously, we're following that number
very closely.
The three numbers we're looking at closely
now are cases, deaths and vaccinations, hospitalizations.
Also an important indicator to look at now,
vaccines in terms of vaccine news and important
studies.
As I said yesterday in our segment about vaccine
alarmism, remember, vaccine alarmism is not
anti vax, vaccine alarmism is something else
we described yesterday, people just being
unnecessarily negative about the impact of
these vaccines, although the effect on transmission
by being vaccinated was not studied by Moderna
and Pfizer.
We are getting more and more early data from
the United Kingdom and Israel, which gets
us closer and closer to being able to say
fully vaccinated people are transmitting,
are able to transmit coronavirus to a much
lesser degree.
Two studies, one from the UK, says that two
doses of the Pfizer vaccine cut transmission
risk by 86 percent.
Now, normal caveats.
This is a preprint.
This wasn't studied in the Phase three trials
by Moderna and Pfizer.
So it is now being studied.
Preprint UK data says transmission down 86
percent among fully vaccinated people.
A study from Israel found an 89 percent reduction
in transmission among fully vaccinated people.
This is good news, which still needs to be
confirmed in peer reviewed settings until
it is confirmed we should not be acting belligerently
once vaccinated.
Now, as far as vaccine supply right now, and
this gets to one of the main questions, which
is when will person A, person B, person C
be able to get a vaccine?
It will vary state to state.
We have seen very uneven rollouts in some
states versus others.
As far as vaccine supply, it looks like the
United States will have enough vaccine for
full vaccination of one hundred and thirty
million people by the end of March.
Now, that's five weeks away.
But remember that it takes up to five weeks
to be fully vaccinated.
What I mean by that is with the Phizer vaccine,
you have 21 days between dose one and two
with the Moderna vaccine, it's 28 days between
dose one and two.
And you're not considered fully protected
until seven days after your second dose.
So if you get the Moderna vaccine, if you
can get it by March 31st, then let's imagine
you get an appointment, you get your second
dose on April 28th, and that means you are
not considered fully protected until roughly
May 5th.
That would be OK.
So it's about a 35 day period from when you
get it until when you're considered fully
vaccinated.
However, there is more good news, and that
is that the third vaccine, the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine, is on the way today.
It has been endorsed for emergency use authorization
by FDA staff.
It now needs to go through the kind of final
final process for emergency use authorization.
That is a one dose vaccine.
The good news is one dose makes logistics
far simpler and X number of doses is good
for twice as many vaccinations.
Right.
If you have ten million doses, but everybody
needs to you can vaccinate five million people.
If you have ten million doses and people only
need one, you can vaccinate ten million people.
The cautious possible downside on the JNJ
vaccine supply is unclear.
And I think we'll just leave it there because
unclear is basically tells you everything
we need to know.
We just don't know yet how much supply of
that will be available, how quickly.
So I think where the facts lead us is to continue
to cautious optimism as far as variants go
will be interviewing Dr. Eric Topol again
soon about the effectiveness of these vaccines
against the three most prevalent variants.
That's a topic of concern right now.
It's looking OK and we'll have more information
about that soon.
And in our interview with Dr. Eric Topol.